[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: All right.
Well, thanks for joining us for
another Talks at Google event.
We're joined today
by chef Adam Sobel.
He's the owner of
the Cinnamon Snail.
[APPLAUSE]
ADAM SOBEL: Thanks, you guys.
MALE SPEAKER: Everyone
already knows you.
It's a four time Vendy award
winning vegan food truck.
He's appeared on the
Food Network and PBS.
And he's written
about vegan food
for "The Vegetarian Times."
You also teach vegan
cooking at the Institute
for Culinary Education.
And Adam's here today to
talk about his new cookbook
and sort of storybook, "Street
Vegan: Recipes and Dispatches
from the Cinnamon
Snail Food Truck."
So thank you for
joining us today.
ADAM SOBEL: Yeah, thanks for
having me here, you guys.
MALE SPEAKER: So let's go back
to the beginning of the story.
Your grandmother was
an inspiration to you.
You talk about her quite often.
Was she the reason you got
into food to begin with?
ADAM SOBEL: Well, I grew up
in a house with a lot of food.
My mom is a literary agent
primarily for cookbook authors.
So there were always people
testing recipes in our home
and even doing photo shoots for
their cookbooks in our home.
And I definitely
started learning cooking
from my mom and
grandma, but really
what got me into preparing
food professionally
was when I met and fell
in love with the woman who
would become my wife, and
who I've had kids with,
in my late teens.
And when I met
her, she was really
one of the first vegan
people I'd gotten close with,
but ate this diet of like
French fries, and canned soup,
and the worst devoid of
nutrition kind of food.
And I wasn't vegan
or vegetarian,
but I really agreed
with the ethics
behind her decision to eat
that way and live that way.
And I really wanted to learn
how to make yummy food so
that I can make great
things for all the time.
And I started just going to
Barnes & Noble's and trying
to copy recipes out of
books and veganize things.
And I started working at
restaurants really just
to start picking up more
tricks to play around with.
And then working
in restaurants, I
myself became vegetarian
and then vegan.
People would come
into the restaurants,
trying to veganize
things or vegetarian
things that were on the menu.
And the other cooks
would scoff about it
and give them a hard time.
And I kept finding myself
standing up for these people
because I agreed with
the ethics behind it.
And eventually,
somebody was like why
aren't you vegetarian yet?
And at that point, I
had no excuses left.
And I was like, yeah,
you're probably right.
And then I got really,
really into it.
MALE SPEAKER: OK, so you start
cooking professionally then
to learn how to cook.
You figured might as
well get paid for it.
I waited tables for
a few weeks terribly.
So I know the restaurant
business is a difficult life.
Did you know going into it
how challenging it would be?
The hours?
That sort of thing, or?
ADAM SOBEL: Well, yeah.
I mean, my first
restaurant gig was
at a restaurant on the
Upper West Side West,
which is one of Tom
Valenti's restaurants.
And I was working
like six days a week,
and I was baking cakes
for people on the side.
And I would have to get on
this 4:00 in the morning bus
from New Jersey,
where I was living,
and drop off cakes I was
delivering on my way to work.
And I worked this
horrendous, long day,
and I would get like 2/3
of my sleep on the bus
to and from the city.
And it was the worst paying job.
I probably wasn't getting even
paid minimum wage or something.
But for me, that was
always way more attractive
than paying to go
to culinary school.
I always really
hated school myself.
And now my kids, we
homeschool our kids.
Because it's just not a
fun way for me to learn.
I'd rather get paid very
little and work long days
to learn that way.
It's more fun for me.
MALE SPEAKER: So you
were in the middle
of the professional
cooking world.
You were a talented chef.
So maybe it's easier
for you to become vegan
because you can prepare
food for yourself.
I know a lot of people say,
oh, I could never be a vegan.
I could never be a vegetarian.
What do you say to people
that feel that way?
ADAM SOBEL: Well,
I mean certainly
when I chose to become a
vegetarian and then vegan,
I wasn't a talented
chef at that point.
I made plenty of
things that sucked.
And to be honest, I still
throw out a terrible meal
every once in awhile.
It happens.
That's part of trying to
get great at something.
You have to be willing
to fail at it miserably
for years and years.
But for me, the reasons
for my becoming vegan
were always very
ethically based.
I think the people
who struggle with it
are choosing to be vegan
maybe for health reasons
or some other dietary concern.
For me, I became really
aware of the suffering
that animals endured to be part
of the food production system.
And it just didn't feel like
it was worth it anymore.
I hesitated becoming vegan
for quite awhile feeling
like it would be
encroaching upon my freedom
to live however I wanted.
And it's really not the case.
Once I became very aware
of how animals are treated
and what they have
to go through-- I
could still eat
animals if I wanted.
I'm perfectly free to do that.
I just don't want to
harm creatures anymore.
So that's made it very
easy to never look back.
MALE SPEAKER: I see.
So you weren't a talented
chef when you started,
you're saying?
ADAM SOBEL: Yeah.
No, I sucked.
MALE SPEAKER: But I think the
lines of the Cinnamon Snail
tell a different story
at least these days.
So as a talented
chef who now has
experience in the food
industry, when you're not
eating the food that
you or your staff
is cooking, what are your
favorite vegan meals?
Maybe around the city, or
around the country, or world?
ADAM SOBEL: Yeah, I mean,
what really attracts
me the most in people's
cooking is really
kind of feeling the love
that they've put in it.
Not to sound really
cliche about it,
but I think it's really evident
in some people's cooking style.
Somebody makes
you a family meal,
and it's their
grandmother's recipe,
and they're making it
feel like they really
care about you--
you just feel such
a different energy in the food.
And for me, it almost
becomes immaterial
what the actual food is.
It's really like
you're being sustained
by their nurturing energy.
I think there's really very
few restaurants in the city
that you can feel that at.
Actually, one of my
favorites that was like that
just closed like last week.
It was the Lan
Vegetarian Restaurant
on Sixth street, which was a
Vietnamese family run business.
You could hear the mom and
dad in the kitchen listening
to Buddhist hymns on loop,
and the son was their waiter.
And it was a really sweet place,
and you felt like you were just
eating in their home.
So I mean, traveling
around, that's what
I gravitate towards when
I travel in India or Asia.
Eating street food
made by somebody
who really cares about
what they're doing,
that's more exciting to me than
eating at the fanciest, most
refined kind of restaurant.
MALE SPEAKER: I see.
So food with love.
And you said you got
into the vegan cooking
to help rescue your future wife
from french fry and canned soup
vegetarianism.
But we all have these
guilty food pleasures.
What would you say yours is?
ADAM SOBEL: Yeah, I'll
fuck up some fried food.
No question about it.
And I really try not to eat that
way regularly because I also
practice a lot of yoga.
And I also really
want-- because I'm
a vegan person who's
semi in the spotlight,
I really want to show people,
look, you can feel great,
and be really healthy,
and have a balanced diet,
and be out there kicking
ass on a vegan diet.
So I don't want to
be way overweight
and not feeling incredible.
But yeah, any kind of potato
product, french fries,
samosas--
MALE SPEAKER: So French fries?
ADAM SOBEL: Yeah, I mean
exactly what I've set out
to not have my wife eating.
She's right.
Pirogis are dope.
Don't get me wrong.
There's a good pirogi
recipe in the book too.
There's a truffled
pirogi recipe.
That's my Achilles Heel.
MALE SPEAKER: So
why then did you
decide to pursue a food
truck instead of a more
traditional restaurant?
ADAM SOBEL: So after the
first restaurant where
I'd been working, which was
not a vegetarian restaurant--
I started working in all
these vegetarian and vegan
restaurants-- I always felt
like the clientele was largely
people who were already
vegan or accepting of it.
And I felt like culturally
we have such a stigma
against vegan and
vegetarian food,
partially because it was
terrible in the '80s and '90s
what most people experienced.
You know, like
macrobiotic-y type food,
and then there was this era
of very, very processed vegan
food, all the fake
meat made in Taiwan.
It's just two
extremes that were not
very good that became the
public's consensus of what
vegan food was about.
And I really wanted to be
able to bring vegan food out
into the world where people
who would never be caught dead
going to a vegan restaurant
would see this huge, long line
down the street.
And there's this display
case of all these
really tempting
looking doughnuts.
And they'd be like lured
into the dark side.
So that was always
my intention with it.
And in my experience,
that's really
what we accomplished with it.
I think, predominantly,
we served
people who really didn't
give a shit about veganism
and were just excited that
it was really yummy food
and available to them right
in front of their office.
And to me, that's the
biggest part of our success.
It's that we've
been able to help
dispel some people's
misconceptions about it
as a culinary form.
MALE SPEAKER: I see.
So it was bringing food out
on the street to the masses,
like the street food that
you like in Southeast Asia
and in that same vein.
Suppose I wanted to
open a food truck.
What should I expect in
terms of what's ahead for me?
I mean, there's this perception
maybe that opening a food truck
is easy whereas opening a
restaurant is difficult.
ADAM SOBEL: Right.
So for years, I would
get a couple people
calling me or emailing me a week
asking me for advice about them
opening a food truck.
And I used to be
all like, aw yeah.
You should go do it.
It's the most fun
thing you ever did.
It's so gratifying.
People come up to
you all day, and they
get really, really
happy in front of you,
and then they leave.
And it's really fun
in that capacity.
But it's kind of the ultimate
food service nightmare too.
It's every problem
that a restaurant has,
because especially in the kind
of complex way we did our food,
we had to have a huge
kitchen facility where
we prepped everything at also.
So we have all the
same different types
of things break, all the
same kind of staffing issues
and problems.
MALE SPEAKER: How many people
worked behind the scenes there?
ADAM SOBEL: Quite
a lot of people.
MALE SPEAKER: A lot.
ADAM SOBEL: By the time
we had a couple trucks,
there was dozens of people.
I mean, it's not [INAUDIBLE].
We gave them Razor scooters
to get around the kitchen.
But it wasn't--
MALE SPEAKER: You
started with two people.
ADAM SOBEL: It wasn't this dope.
But yeah, it's extremely
prone to disaster.
In addition to all the
things restaurants deal with,
then there's you breaking down,
and there's parking tickets,
and people have this really
confrontational thing
with food trucks.
Like, the pizza
place up the block
feels like you're
unfair competition,
and they'll call
the police on you.
And then especially
in New York City,
the laws are very different
city to city, but in New York,
it's ridiculous.
Essentially, food
trucks are more or less
illegal in the city.
There's this illegal black
market, which is the only way
to obtain the permits for them.
And then once you even get all
the permits, and insurance,
and everybody's
got workers' comp,
and everything's as legit
as you can possibly make it,
they've made it
as of a few years
ago so that you're not legally
even allowed to serve food
if you're at a metered
location, which
is every single commercial
space in Manhattan.
So you could be in
a busy lunch rush,
and police just come
and say you guys
aren't allowed to operate
in front of a meter.
You've got to go.
So yeah, it's like every
nightmare of a restaurant
but multiplied.
It became almost like a
joke between me and my wife.
Every day, there's always
some absurd thing happening.
It's fun.
And for me, it was
really worth it
because I was
motivated by trying
to change our
culture a little bit
and trying to get the mainstream
to think a little bit more
compassionately.
So as far as I'm concerned,
enduring all these
like hurdles and
issues, it's sort
of a matter of life and
death for the animals
who people ended up not eating.
So it was very, very worth it.
But yeah, most
people who just want
to run whatever
kind of-- they want
to do a waffle truck because
it's trendy right now.
Now I just tell them you could
save yourself so many headaches
by doing it as a restaurant
and not a food truck.
MALE SPEAKER: So you mentioned
this shady black market
of permitting.
So I'm curious about this.
Without implicating
me, making me
a conspirator in any
way, what can you tell me
about these shady permits that
people-- not you, I'm sure--
are acquiring out there.
ADAM SOBEL: Right.
So yeah, as of the early
'80s in New York City,
this cap was placed on the
number of vending permits
both for trucks and carts
it's the same permit.
And when they went in
place, anyone who had them
was able to keep
renewing them for about
the cost of $100 a year.
So they realized now
there's this heavy demand
for these permits, and they
can keep holding on to them
and renewing them and
renting them out illegally
from more than 100 times
what they look they're worth.
And there's no other way.
You can't get on a waiting
list because nobody's
going to let theirs expiring
go back into the system.
So it's amazing in
New York City, which
you feel is like hyper
controlled environment
where there's police everywhere.
But still so many things are
regulated in this shady fashion
in New York.
It's the same for
taxicab medallions,
and liquor licenses, and
a variety of other things.
So that actually prevented
us from opening up initially
in New York City because we
just couldn't even find one.
It took a couple years before
we are able to obtain one,
and it was the shadiest thing
I've ever had to deal with.
I bought drugs when I was a kid
on the street in New York City.
This was way, way
more shady than that.
And it's large sums
of money in cash
you're handling some guy in
an industrial area of Queens
in a paper bag.
It's horrendous.
I don't recommend having to
do that to run your business.
MALE SPEAKER: That's exactly
out of the movies basically.
ADAM SOBEL: Yeah.
I regularly had to deal with the
cast of the Sopranos and stuff.
MALE SPEAKER: So while we're
on the subject of bureaucracy,
what are the health regulations
and health inspections
like for food trucks?
Are they different
from restaurants?
ADAM SOBEL: Yeah, actually
it's another really big
misconception people
have about food trucks.
Because I guess 20
or 30 years ago,
they were this completely
unregulated outlaw thing.
I mean, now a food truck gets
way more meticulously health
inspected and way
more frequently
because they're going to
all different neighborhoods.
So they'll jump on the
truck at your busiest time
ever and be looking with a
flashlight at the underside
of the corner of the
counters for any--
it's really very difficult.
So food trucks really have
to be up on their game
because the fines are enormous.
And they can shut
you down completely.
So just like a restaurant
has, food trucks
have to have all the same
working hand washing facilities
and all this type of stuff,
which is a huge challenge.
Your restaurant parks outside in
the winter, and all your pipes
want to freeze
every night, and it
becomes this whole
other dimension of crap
to have to worry about to be
able to be up to health code.
But it's doable.
It's just hard.
MALE SPEAKER: I see.
So it seems like the
bureaucrats, the policemen,
they can either be your best
friend or your worst nightmare.
In "Street Vegan," you
tell an interesting story
about an experience
you had in Hoboken
with a police officer
who gave you a hard time.
Can you talk about that?
ADAM SOBEL: Sure.
So Hoboken, like I was saying,
all the towns and cities
have their own unique
ordinances about vending.
And Hoboken's one
was really weird.
It was that you had
to move your food
truck after every single sale.
You know in the suburbs, like
the roving ice cream trucks?
They'll throw you an ice cream
out the window type of thing?
It can only work for
pre-packaged junk food type
products, you know?
If you're setting up an official
kitchen on the street, that
takes at least 45 minutes
to just get everything
settled, and the grills
lit, and all this stuff.
So like it is in
New York where you
have to find this
balance of where to park,
where nobody's going to
call the police on you,
and these types of
things, in Hoboken, it
was like you had to find a
spot where you could stay,
and had good enough
foot traffic,
and nobody was going to
bother you-- somewhere
on the outskirts of town.
MALE SPEAKER: Where you
might do a cash deal.
ADAM SOBEL: Yeah, it was very
typical of food truck world.
So in the first week or
two I was operating, still
really learning the ropes of
how all this stuff worked.
We opened on Valentine's Day of
2010, and it was freezing cold.
The first day we were
shoveling feet of snow
off the roof of our truck
when we were opening.
And it was so slow on
this one waterfront block
that I had found that
was kind of safe that I
started venturing deeper into
the downtown area of Hoboken.
And this one morning I set up,
and after making a couple sales
this cop came in
full Gestapo leather.
He's the policeman from
hell type of character.
And he's like, oh yeah.
You've got to move right now.
So it was early on
a Sunday morning.
I saw there was a spot across
the block, so I went over there
and I opened up.
And I sold somebody
in order of pancakes,
and immediately
the guy was back.
He was like, I'm going to keep
following you around all today.
You gotta keep moving.
And I didn't really get it.
And I was packing up slowly so
he came back and immediately
issued me $500 in tickets.
He made it clear he was going
to just make my day hell.
And I had a whole truck full
of freshly made doughnuts
and all this stuff that was
just going to go to waste.
And I knew I had to just pack
up for the day at that point.
And thinking about it,
just driving out of town
I stopped at the
police precinct.
And I was like, OK.
Here's all the doughnuts
I have, you guys.
I don't even know what to
expect tomorrow when I come back
to operate in this town.
And I came back the next
day, and I felt bad.
The guy had been so mad
at me, this policeman.
So I went to the police
station and I asked for him
by name, the police officer.
And I introduced myself.
And I was like, look.
I'm really not
trying to be a dick.
I just want to make
vegetarian food for people.
And immediately just because
I had talked to him about it,
he was a little bit nicer.
And a week later, I was serving
again food on the waterfront
and I saw this
police car pull up.
And I'm on the phone with my
wife because it's real slow.
And I'm like, oh shit.
The police are here.
I've gotta go.
And it's the policeman.
He comes out, and he
orders all this food.
And there's a couple
people waiting on food.
And he's giving
them rave reviews,
telling them which
doughnuts to get.
He started bringing
other cops there,
and they'd get tofu
sandwiches and stuff.
So yeah, if you're ever harassed
by the police, it's true.
You just have to feed them
truckloads of doughnuts
and it fixes all your problems.
MALE SPEAKER: Wow.
And that just works, huh?
ADAM SOBEL: Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: So I guess
speaking of the food,
let's start talking more
about the food instead
of the bureaucracy, as
interesting as all that is.
You mentioned how every
once and a while, you'll
have to throw out a meal that
you made that's just no good.
You're constantly
experimenting with dishes
and that sort of stuff.
What are your current
most exciting experiments?
Can't you share any with us?
Or do they stay top secret
until they see the light of day?
ADAM SOBEL: No.
I mean, there's so much stuff.
I'm always experimenting,
especially at home
with my wife who does
a lot of pastry stuff.
So we're constantly tweaking
and perfecting new things.
And there are
things too that I'll
come to be great at
making, and I always
feel like I can
get better at it.
I mean, a perfect example
are the doughnuts we make,
which there's a very
comprehensive chapter
for in the book.
It's something
that I'm constantly
playing with and tweaking
different methods
for exactly how they're glazed.
And if you glaze the doughnuts
while the doughnuts themselves
are still warm, it has
a very different effect
than if you glaze
them after they've
cooled, because the
warmth of the doughnut
makes the glaze drip
down in a thinner way.
And there's constantly
stuff like that.
Another thing which you guys
had in the cafeteria today
are the [? bo ?]
buns, which there's
a few recipes for in the book.
It's like a Chinese
style steam bun.
And I'm really tweaking
the method I do that with,
because I have this great idea
about doing vegan hamburgers
on Chinese style steam buttons.
So to make it work out
as a real burger bun
it takes some tweaking so
that's still soft and wonderful
but can be substantial.
MALE SPEAKER: So
I'd imagine that one
of the challenges for this
book is taking recipes
that you normally make
for hundreds of thousands
and making it so that I can
make five at home or something
like that.
What was the process you
went through in terms
of picking recipes and then
coming up with measurements
that a home cook could follow?
And how do you know that the
recipes come out good in a home
kitchen?
ADAM SOBEL: Yeah.
Really, all the
recipes had to be
recreated from the ground up.
We do them in such large volumes
and use industrial equipment
for making them that it
really only made sense
to figure out instead of
doing the math of dividing
the recipe we have by
2000, figuring it out fresh
and really approximating
the taste perfectly.
And then I had a great
collection of different recipe
testers I worked with.
And I really tried to have
both people who are really
novice cooks and people who
were more professional so
that the people who
really knew about cooking
could point out the
stupid mistakes I've made,
and the people who were
terrible at cooking
would ask me the
dumb questions that I
assumed people might know.
So that really helped
me hone things.
But the thing about doing the
book for me that was really fun
is that on the truck
itself we're really
limited in the kind of equipment
we have for serving food.
We really just have a flat
top griddle on the truck.
So doing the book
really allowed me
to start having recipes
available to people for things
that I wish we could offer--
dumplings on the truck,
and there's all these really
hooked up entrees in the truck
as well.
So that was really
a fun opportunity.
MALE SPEAKER: So there's
recipes in the book
that people have
never seen if they've
been to the Cinnamon Snail?
ADAM SOBEL: For sure.
Some of it are things
that we've always
offered for catering and stuff.
The entrees, it's kind of funny.
A lot of them we did used
to have on the truck.
Because when I first
opened the truck,
I thought it'd be
this great idea
to not have any sandwiches
whatsoever on our truck, which
has become synonymous
with what we do.
But I just wanted to have all
these architectural, beautiful
entrees all stacked up with
beautiful fried garnishes
on them and stuff.
And so when I opened, I had
like 13 different entrees
on the truck and maybe like
a sandwich or something.
And it's a completely
absurd impractical idea
I had that people
would be willing to eat
that on a paper plate in their
lap during their lunch time.
So that's why the food
we do on the truck
gravitated so much towards
it being like almost a whole
entree in between
two pieces of bread.
Some of the things
we serve on the truck
are really complex like that.
MALE SPEAKER: And so you have
some very complex recipes.
And in the book, you helpfully
go through all the ingredients
you'll see later in the
book and what they are.
So there are a lot
of ingredients,
and some folks here,
especially in Manhattan,
don't have gigantic kitchens.
What are the must haves
for a good vegan kitchen?
ADAM SOBEL: Well, I mean,
I guess everybody's tastes
are different.
But definitely one
of my desert island,
I get to bring one
seasoning ingredient with me
to the desert island, is plum
vinegar, the umeboshi plum
vinegar.
It's kind of in an
embarrassing number of things
I make because I
love it so much.
It really has this
very bright umame kind
of salty, tangy flavor.
You would think plum vinegar
sounds so sweet and fruity,
but it's this really tangy--
really brings things to life.
It's great in all kinds of
dressings, and marinades,
and sauces.
I use it even in soups.
But yeah, it's really
a great seasoning.
That's definitely
one of my go-to.
MALE SPEAKER: That's a
must have for your kitchen?
ADAM SOBEL: Yeah, I mean,
there are so many things
that we use on the truck
that we rely on it,
and it allows us to do a very
simple preparation with it
that's versatile.
So for instance in the book,
which we use on the truck,
there's a recipe for just
very simply marinaded
kale that is just
massaged with plum
vinegar and extra virgin
olive oil, some black pepper,
and thyme.
And it's a very simple,
easy to make recipe,
and it makes the greens
really easily digestible
because the acidity
of the vinegar
penetrates the cells of the
greens and makes it soft,
almost like sauteed greens.
But it doesn't impart a very
specific flavor profile on it,
so we'll use that
same marinaded kale
in a variety of different
things on the truck.
It's in our Korean
barbecue seitan,
and it's also on the
Thanksgiving style sandwich
we do.
And it works easily for both.
MALE SPEAKER: And
so greens, that's
a dish that people are
comfortable making vegan.
You're known for doughnuts
and pastries, which
are dishes that people probably
don't know how to make vegan
or that non-vegans
are surprised to taste
and there's no animal
products in them.
So how do you veganize pastries?
Is it all your wife?
Has she got the secret
recipes for that?
ADAM SOBEL: She is magical,
but it's taken a lot of us
both tweaking the recipes.
And I mean, to be
honest, I think
most people wouldn't
know how to make a not
vegan doughnut either.
It's not something that
a lot of people do.
And to be honest,
it's a pastry art form
that I feel was
almost completely lost
during the '70s
through the '90s.
Really, this industrialized
model of doughnut production
started proliferating,
stuff like Krispy Kreme,
and Dunkin' Donuts,
and Tim Horton's.
And really, the
kind of mom and pop
handmade doughnut tradition
was almost completely
lost because it was something as
a culinary form that was never
really very well documented.
There's only a
couple very-- I mean,
there's not many books about it.
Most resources online
about doughnut making start
with a can of Pillsbury
muffin mix or whatever.
And it's something that
learning to do vegan,
we really had to
start with nothing
and just start making
stuff up and trying things.
And writing a doughnut
chapter for the book
was a really
interesting challenge
because it's not the type
of thing you can just
hand somebody a recipe for
and expect them to pull it off
with finesse.
There's kind of a
lot of variables that
can really make or break it.
We created these
doughnut recipes,
and that we would figure one
day would come out amazing,
and the next day
they'd be horrible
and had soaked up all this oil.
And we would start noticing
the exact amount of time
that the doughnut sit before
you actually form them
into doughnuts, the dough sits
so that the liquids really
hydrate the cells of the flour.
It really matters.
And you know exactly
how frequently
you filter the oil if
you're frying doughnuts
every day if you're not
throwing out the entire $700
fryer worth of
doughnut oil every day.
You have to filter it very
frequently because the oil
starts transforming.
So in writing that
chapter, I had
to lay down a little
bit of a primer
on exactly some of
those variables,
exactly how long you want
to mix the dough for,
and how to proof the
doughnuts if you don't have
a commercial proofing oven.
So yeah, it forced me
to get really creative
and think of all these things.
MALE SPEAKER: I see.
So both you and your wife
have the cooking skills.
Who does most of
the cooking at home?
ADAM SOBEL: I do most
of the cooking at home
just because I'm a lot
faster than she is.
MALE SPEAKER: No one
has time to wait for--
ADAM SOBEL: Well, yeah.
I mean, we've got two kids
who always want to eat 24/7.
MALE SPEAKER: What are
their most requested dishes?
What do the kids want?
ADAM SOBEL: Well,
my six year-old
would eat burritos three
times a day if I let her.
But what are the real big
hits in our household?
The blintzes I make
are really a big hit,
and there's a really
great, solid recipe
for that in our book, which is
based off of my grandmother's
method for it.
It's filled with kasha
and fried onions.
And there's the method for
making really good quality
homemade applesauce and tofu
sour cream and stuff with it.
There's also a soup
that's in the book
that I make a lot at home
that's a coconut curry super
with chickpeas and Thai basil.
My wife and kids
went to Thailand
about a year or so
ago, and they're
so addicted to Thai food now.
So I've had to get
really, really legit.
Because at the beginning, I
would make stuff for them,
and they'd be like, oh,
this is good Thai good.
And then they went to
Thailand, and I really
had to step up my game.
MALE SPEAKER: And they knew you
had been lying the whole time.
ADAM SOBEL: Yeah.
It was like, aw, I was trying
to pass off Cambodian food
and then they found out.
So--
MALE SPEAKER: I see.
So a lot of Thai food
around the Sobel household.
ADAM SOBEL: Well, at
home, we eat pretty simply
for the most part.
We eat a lot of really
vegetable-based meals.
We try to have-- especially
because we have two kids we've
been raising since
birth vegan, I really
put a lot of extra
effort into making
sure they have a very
well rounded diet
and they get a lot of
dark greens in their diet
so they're really thriving.
MALE SPEAKER: So due to all this
permitting hassle and the food
truck life getting to
you, the Cinnamon Snail's
recently retired its daily
lunch service here in New York.
Where can we get all this
food you're talking about?
ADAM SOBEL: I mean, how?
You can buy it in
your own kitchen.
It's in my book.
MALE SPEAKER: That's
just what you would say.
You should buy the book.
Cook it at home.
ADAM SOBEL: Yeah, we're running
the truck here and there
at events in New York.
There's the monthly vegan shop
up events that are in Brooklyn.
There's the seed market
that's by the Altman
building on 18th Street that
we'll be doing once a month.
And then outside of
New York in New Jersey,
our New York City permit
nightmares don't apply there.
So we'll be operating at the
Red Bank New Jersey Farmers'
Market and hopefully the Jersey
City Farmers' Market as well.
But yeah, we're doing a
little bit of catering.
I'm conspiring my
next, big, crazy thing.
MALE SPEAKER: What's the
next, big, crazy thing?
You can tell us.
It's just between
me, you, and YouTube.
ADAM SOBEL: No.
MALE SPEAKER: You really can't?
ADAM SOBEL: I'm going to
have to keep you waiting.
But there's some fun
thing brewing in my brain,
and then I'm also doing
consulting for a couple
different brands to help them
develop vegan lines of what
it is that they do.
MALE SPEAKER: And
there's always as you
mentioned the catering custom
cakes and that sort of stuff.
ADAM SOBEL: Yeah, my wife makes
really beautiful wedding cakes
and stuff for people.
MALE SPEAKER: And the
rest of us will just have
to wait to find out where the--
ADAM SOBEL: You
guys have to hope
to get invited to a wedding,
and then you can eat her cakes.
MALE SPEAKER: Well,
that's incentive
to get married too if anyone's
been holding out on that.
So I think we've got
a great conversation,
but I'd imagine people
have questions for you.
If anyone has questions,
if you could make your way
to one of the two mics, and--
ADAM SOBEL: Just be warned
I can't see you guys at all.
We're blinded up here.
But ask me questions.
AUDIENCE: Hey, Adam.
Thanks for coming.
I live in downtown
Jersey City, and I'm
looking forward to you hopefully
being at the farmers' market.
I wanted to ask you.
I don't know if you're aware.
The owner of Two Boots Pizza
has mobilized a coalition
of other-- Do you
know where I'm?
ADAM SOBEL: Yeah, yeah.
AUDIENCE: He mobilized a
coalition of restaurants
that they're basically
trying to push out
the food trucks and
the prepared meals
at the farmers' market,
which really pisses me off.
What do you think we as
residents of Jersey City
can do to counteract that?
ADAM SOBEL: That's
a good question.
I know the Jersey
City Farmers' Market
is curated by the downtown
historic improvement district
there, which is a good thing
as far as our being there
is concerned, because
they're sort of the city
government-oriented branch.
It's the cause for a
lot of the headaches
we have dealt with
in the city too.
There's a lot of
businesses who just
feel that food trucks are an
unfair form of competition
and want them out.
And unfortunately, because
they pay the property
taxes in that town and we
don't, they have a lot more
say than we do about it.
But if you're a resident there,
you also have some say in it.
So I don't know if there are
council meetings or hearings
about these issues
that you can attend,
but certainly speaking up for
food trucks in that capacity
would be helpful.
I don't really know exactly
how it's going there.
AUDIENCE: I went to the meeting
where the Two Boots guys,
he made a very passionate,
well practiced speech.
And I didn't speak.
I didn't sign up ahead of time.
But it's effective, because
now in the Grove Square,
the food trucks
aren't there anymore.
And I know at lunchtime
they have issues
that they keep having to move.
And I think it's
detrimental to the people,
ultimately, in terms of choice.
ADAM SOBEL: Yeah,
I mean, I think
it's the council member Steve
Fulop there is kind of--
AUDIENCE: He's the mayor.
ADAM SOBEL: Is he the mayor now?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
ADAM SOBEL: OK, when
I was in Hoboken,
and he was just
a council member.
AUDIENCE: Former councilman.
ADAM SOBEL: I mean, he doesn't
like food trucks either.
He wears the big
pants in Jersey City.
But Two Boots guy,
if you're listening,
I challenge you to a
rap battle or something.
We can sort it out.
I think that folks who really
take issue with food trucks
have this like absurd, outdated
mentality about business.
And they don't really
understand how much
foot traffic we bring to the
neighborhoods that we visit.
And I hope he comes, and
we'll do the rap battle.
We'll get it sorted out.
AUDIENCE: Looking forward to it.
Thank you.
MALE SPEAKER: The truckload of
doughnuts worked with the cops.
Is it possible
that that would be
a lobbying technique for you?
ADAM SOBEL: Well, if it's
pizza guys I'm up against,
they already eat
mad dough products.
MALE SPEAKER: I say go straight
to the straight to the mayor
though.
I mean, ultimately,
the Two Boots guy--
ADAM SOBEL: You know, the
problem is for food trucks
that no matter where
we operate, there's
always many forms of
opposition to face.
And all over the
country, there's
been these food truck
coalitions starting up.
In New York City, there's
the Street Vendor Project
and the New York City
Food Truck Association,
which both try to fight
for vendors' rights.
But we're the smallest
type of small businesses
versus every
Starbucks in New York
City who has lobbying
power and all this stuff.
AUDIENCE: I wonder if,
just on that topic,
I wonder if there's
an opportunity
to offer your goods for sale
within Two Boots, right?
Prepare the food.
Bring it to them.
Let them sell it.
That will bring way more foot
traffic into their store.
Maybe they'll get on
your side that way.
I would go there.
I also live in Jersey City.
Hi.
Thank you so much for coming.
We bring in some
of the luminaries
of the world in terms
of genius scientists
and interesting people
in the tech world
to give talks like these.
But you know all the
most exciting people
that, for me
personally, you're it.
ADAM SOBEL: Aww!
AUDIENCE: I tried to start
eating vegan three years ago.
I had very serious health
issues that I couldn't get over,
and switching to
vegan really fixed it.
And the first time
I had Cinnamon Snail
in Jersey City, that was
when I switched from saying
"eating vegan really sucks, but
it's making me healthy so I'm
going to do it" to "this
is freaking awesome.
I've never had anything
like this before."
So thanks so much for doing that
and then also bringing it here
to work after the
truck went away,
which was the most depressing
time in my time in Jersey City.
I wanted to tell you
that so you know.
But what I really wanted to
ask about is the word vegan.
I feel like there's
such a stigma associated
with the word for really
no good reason, right?
I mentioned that
your food is here
today to some of my colleagues,
and that it's really, really
amazing and they should take
the trip to the 8th floor
make it happen.
And they said, yeah, I'm a
meat and potatoes kind of guy.
I'm not that adventurous.
And there's really
nothing adventurous
about not eating
animal products,
like having some vegetables or
tofu or something like that.
But that's the attitude
about the word vegan.
And before I became vegan
or start eating vegan food,
my mother-in-law used
that word all the time.
And as somebody who was not
someone who ate in that way,
I found it very offensive.
Like, you think
you're better than me?
You make vegan food?
You're some fancy vegan?
I'm just wondering that given
that it has such a stigma,
and vegetarian has much less of
a stigma because it sounds more
like the word
vegetable, I guess,
is there a way to
maybe-- I think
there is a movement towards more
people believing that the vegan
eating is a more sustainable
way to run the planet
and it's healthier for people
and people generally like it,
but people also generally
dislike the word.
I wonder if there's a way to
come up with a new marketing
campaign like "eat for
life" or "pro-animal."
ADAM SOBEL: Yeah, I mean, people
are calling it plant-based.
There's all these different
words that have been coined.
But I mean, I think
what our culture
is dealing with is more
deeply psychological, right?
The excuse that people
are afraid that's
not going to be yummy or that
it's not going to make them
feel great-- there's all
these different excuses,
but I think more
fundamentally it's
because it's an ethical
attempt to really try to limit
the violence we cause, right?
It forces people
to observe the way
they've lived their whole life
and that's very painful when
you realize you've been
living in such a way
your whole life
that's indirectly
caused a lot of suffering.
And it's something
that a lot of people
would rather keep out of
sight and out of mind.
So people get really
defensive about it
and will become very
offensive towards veganism
because it challenges
their moral ideology.
Not to get real
philosophical about it,
but I think that's a really
big part of our culture's
opposition towards
it, not to say
that it's even a perfect
model in and of itself.
I mean, there's a
lot of varieties
of ways people can eat
in a vegan way that are
more or less nonviolent, right?
But I think that's really
what a lot of folks
struggle with about it.
I don't think it needs to
be marketed differently.
I think our culture
just needs to take
a little more time with it
before it really can accept it
and comprehended
it in its fullest.
AUDIENCE: All right.
Thanks so much.
ADAM SOBEL: Hey.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Adam.
Thank you so much for coming.
I have one and a half questions.
The first is, what you're
drinking looks really yummy.
I was just wondering what it is.
ADAM SOBEL: It's the best!
This is yerba mate.
It's a tea from
Argentina and Uruguay.
The straw is called
a bombilla, which
has this strainer at
the bottom, and it's
a lot of very thick herbs.
It's really tasty,
in my opinion,
but it's one of these things
that people love or hate.
It's almost got a
tobacco-y quality
in some weird way, a very
all around your mouth palette
experience.
But it's sort of great for you.
I think it's probably
like 90% what
I'm made out of because
I consume a lot of it.
But yeah, it's like a
multivitamin in some ways.
It's got a ton of amino
acids and minerals,
lots of B vitamins, magnesium.
That's what it is.
AUDIENCE: That's very cool.
I like tea a lot.
My actual question is I'm
curious where the name Cinnamon
Snail originated.
ADAM SOBEL: Well, I get
asked this question a lot,
and honestly, I wish I
had a cooler background
story because then I
would have this cool story
to tell all the time.
But really it just sounds cute.
It's another name for cinnamon
buns, which my wife and I were
making for our local
farmers' market
before we launched the truck.
And really the
translation in Danish,
I believe it's
kanelsnegle, is what
you call a cinnamon
bun, which directly
translates to cinnamon snail.
But yeah, really it
just sounds cute.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ADAM SOBEL: Yeah.
Hey.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
Thanks so much for coming.
I one time stopped
by the Cinnamon Snail
immediately before a bus
back home to Virginia.
And now my folks expect
a donut every time
I come back so
you've really helped
me raise the expectations
for me as a son.
So I have a question.
There's a part that's of
personal interest to me,
and then something that other
people might find interesting.
My landlord shut off my
gas like a month ago,
and there's no word on
when that's coming back.
And so I guess the more
microquestion is do you
have any good recipes that only
use a slow cooker and a rice
cooker?
ADAM SOBEL: What you need to
get is an induction burner,
like an electric
induction burner.
Then you could cook a
lot of things with that.
Yeah, there's not too many Easy
Bake Oven recipes in my book.
Yeah, get yourself
an induction burner.
But get your
landlord in trouble.
That's not right.
You gotta get some gas back on.
AUDIENCE: I'm working on it.
OK, and then I guess my
more interesting question
is sort of related to that.
I take it that
cooking in the truck
and then cooking in
like a real kitchen--
not that your truck doesn't
have a real kitchen,
but a more traditional
kitchen is very different.
And do you find that the
constrained environment
of the truck has led you to be
more creative with your recipes
in any way?
ADAM SOBEL: That's an
interesting question.
Well, the format of
the truck and the fact
that we became this
astronomically busy food
truck that has-- it's
a very limited space
you have in a truck, and you can
only fit so many people in it
to be preparing the food.
So more than anything what it
really causing me to rethink
is ways we could prepare
this food as quickly
as humanly possible without it
diminishing from the complexity
and the freshness of it.
I don't know how much that's
reflected in the book,
because the book doesn't
have those same constraints.
But what it did is force
me to also plan ways
we could prepare the different
components of the food
so it was really just the very
quick reheating and assembly
of things on the truck.
We have this 5,000 square foot
production kitchen in Brooklyn
where we make all the different
sauces and things like that.
But yeah, it was a
really fun challenge,
and that's something
that's really always been
attractive to me
creatively-- forcing myself
to deal with these irrational
types of challenges as a cook
or in any creative capacity.
That's one of the things
that's been fun for me to learn
how to make vegan food like.
At first, it almost
seemed like you're
cooking with one hand
tied behind your back.
And then how you're
going to prepare food
for some guest who
comes who's paleo
and you want it to be vegan too.
I love that type of stuff.
Or be on some show
and you've gotta
make this huge ass meal
in 30 minutes or whatever?
That stuff's really fun to me.
So that always gets
me excited creatively.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
Well, Kitchen Stadium is
right across the street,
and so I hope to see
you there sometime soon.
ADAM SOBEL: Yeah, I'd
like to throw down.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so much.
ADAM SOBEL: Hey, Adam.
Really quick question.
Kickstarter-- can you walk
you through your decision
to try to raise
money on Kickstarter
and whether you think that's a
good platform for food trucks
or restaurants specifically?
ADAM SOBEL: Right, so
so we did a Kickstarter
for our second truck, which
became the most successful food
truck-related Kickstarter ever.
And it was really
out of necessity.
Without getting too
deeply back into all
the permit-related
stuff, we were
waiting on a permit
renewal for our one truck,
and it was going to take months.
Because with the
black market we were
going to have to fly the
permit holder back in Pakistan
to be there for it.
And anyway, the easiest way
to be back open in business
immediately was to buy
somebody else's fully already
outfitted food truck that
had a permit on it already.
And it was really expensive
to do that, and largely
at the expense of that was
because of the permit that
was-- this sticker
that was on the truck.
We got really screwed
in that transaction
in that when we bought the food
truck from its previous owners,
the permittee who saw that the
food truck was changing hands
and who had already been paid
in full for the next two years
of the rental of
his permit decided
that he could rent
that permit to somebody
else at the same time.
So he reported that one stolen.
So he went and got a
new copy of his permit
and rented it out
to some other truck.
And then a couple months down
the road, we got inspected
and they were like your
permit's reported stolen.
You're fucked.
Not to say that that's going
to happen to everybody.
It's a difficult thing.
I think some food
trucks have initially
gotten their start
on Kickstarter,
but it's hard for most people
to do that if they don't already
have this huge social media
following, and reputation,
and stuff.
There's probably millions
of people throughout America
who want somebody to buy them
a food truck because they think
they're great cook or whatever.
So I don't know if it's
the way into food truck
heaven for everybody,
but it got us back up
and running in a few weeks
and was very helpful.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
We have time for one more.
ADAM SOBEL: OK, let's do it.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Adam.
I miss your food
truck in New York.
ADAM SOBEL: Aw, I do too.
AUDIENCE: Correct me if I'm
wrong if I'm remembering this
wrong, but your truck
had a policy where
if anyone who was basically
looked like they're
homeless or pretty poor,
they'd just be given
free food and free coffee.
ADAM SOBEL: Mhm.
AUDIENCE: How did you
decide that would just
be a policy you do even
though you were a very
large business at that point?
Did it start small and
just become your policy?
I just also wanted to comment
that that was amazing.
I just saw it happen
one day, and then
I actually looked
at your website
and it said something
about that this is just
your policy or whatnot.
So how did that come about
that that just became
what happened at your truck?
ADAM SOBEL: Right.
I guess about 10 years ago or
so, I traveled to South India
for the first time.
And for some reason I
had all these bananas
that somebody gave me the
week before I went to India.
So I made like a
shitload of banana bread,
and I brought it to the
city with me on my way
to the plane to India.
And I was going to give out the
banana bread to homeless people
or whatever.
And I had one piece left
that I hadn't found somebody
to give it to, and I just
brought it with me to India.
And I figure, aw, I'll just
give it to somebody in India.
This'll be cool.
And my first day in
South India immediately
from leaving my hotel
room there was this alley.
And this kid crawled
out of the alley
who looked to be the same
age as my daughter did,
probably like two
years old or so.
And she was missing
her arms and stuff,
and she was living in
garbage in this alley.
And I gave her my banana
bread, and I was like, wow,
this is going to be such
a heavy kind of trip
here in South India.
And on that trip,
you know, there's
such desperation throughout
a lot of India and Southeast
Asia, such severe poverty.
And it's so easy to help people
in a third world country where
you could buy them a whole
for the equivalent of $0.20,
you know?
Or bring somebody
to the hospital
for the equivalent of $20
for a life changing surgery.
And on that trip, I just
decided I could never
say no to somebody
again who's in need.
So that really shaped
my business practices,
and even just how I live.
I could never not
give somebody money
who's asking for money
and stuff like that.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
MALE SPEAKER: Thank you so
much for joining us today.
ADAM SOBEL: Yeah, thanks
for having me, you guys.
MALE SPEAKER: Buy
"Street Vegan."
Cook the doughnuts at home.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.